on this episode I talk about CTAs 24/7
community management and buying the Jets
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching episode 22 of the
askgaryvee show fun fact about the
number 22 that's how much some Jets are
gonna win tonight over the Bears
36:14 who wants to know if you bought
the Jets today it would be the first
thing you would do
Lou I've always said that the first
thing I would do once I buy these New
York Jets I'm pointing to the stadium by
the way
is I would start a program that would
send the Jersey to every six-year-old
boy and girl in the New York New Jersey
tri-state area with a handwritten note
from me saying thank you or maybe just a
note that I would sign some because
that's a big number but I want to
basically convert every single youth
into the green not the blue and so that
would be the number one thing I would do
start the program that I've been
imagining and dreaming about my whole
life MIDI wants to know what motivates
you to continue any project like Wine
Library without seeing any significant
growth prior buddy you know for me
that's a very easy answer which is I
just believe in my holistic purpose
right I'm blown away by how many people
are crippled by one project or the other
to me this is a net-net game I have a
very clear vision professionally where I
want to go but overall I just want to be
a good human being do business the right
way the right process put in the right
hustle and I control that if I don't get
results well that means I made a wrong
strategic decision but that doesn't
[ __ ] me either because there's a
net-net I know where I'm going so for
every one or two times I decide to get
in the wrong business or invest in the
wrong thing I'm going to figure out a
win alongside of that and that's all
that really matters to me Michael wants
to know as an entrepreneur how do you
feel about government officials picking
winners like win gaining approval for
casino in Boston Michael first and
foremost I agree with you 100% this kind
of government interface
behind-the-scenes stuff happens all day
long especially non-american it happens
in America all day long but you start
getting into other parts of the world
there's a lot of shenanigans going on
but I'll be honest with you as an
entrepreneur and I've always felt this
way and don't forget I come from a
regulated industry business where Wine
Library had plenty of headaches I just
completely diss I just completely ignore
it I'm disinterested and not focused on
it at all I spent all of my time and I
mean all of it I spent all of my time of
the things that I can control it's why I
fear the health and well-being of the
people I love and care for because I'm
not in control but when it comes to
business even though there's a lot of
back-end deals
people not rooting for me deals that
were made for me not to win I feel that
I have the talent and the skills to
spill breakthrough Haley wants to know
what is your response to brands looking
for 24/7 community management is it
worth the investment is it overkill
you know Haley I'm a big fan I believe
that everybody that you engage with and
say hello to I believe that everybody I
said thanks to orti why over the weekend
for watching all 21 episodes of the show
get affected by that I do think the
human investment matters I do think that
if brands committed more to one-on-one
marketing that many of them don't think
is scalable they would get bigger depth
we talked in the last episode about
depth and width a lot of you responded
to that I think the community management
24/7 can be valuable if you're big
enough you have to be a global brand you
have to be a Pepsi you have to be a
Toyota to really get the value out of
24/7 because otherwise you're paying
people to sit around and not engage
within you I'm not crushing it on
Twitter between 2:00 a.m. Eastern and 6
a.m. Eastern so I don't need anybody in
which in this case is me engaging there
but if you're big enough I believe in it
ok I get it
go native go deep jab jab jab jab big
right hook but it becomes to the
mechanics of making sales online you
need identification call the action know
both here and on your facebook posts you
have no links no email signup you just
trust that with enough goodwill and
trust people will find your website
flash email when it's time to buy if I
need my content to drive bookings
should I not at least have a link or
more info when people are ready for it
thanks big G Jason you know what can you
catching me on episode 22 because my
favorite new rookie on the Jets is Jace
Amaro our tight end so I'm gonna give
you that listen spoken like a real
salesman and I'm a real salesman I'm a
real salesman but you're not wrong I'm
all about the CTR right the call to
action I'm into that right but at the
end of the day you're talking about the
difference between sales
ship and branding anybody could be a
good salesman but being a great brand er
that's where it gets going the lift of
being a brand being a Nike being a puma
versus just selling a new sneaker that's
a big difference and so tactically
you're correct that I'm sure a lot of
people who watch this think about those
things where why didn't Garry create a
clothes action why does he go pop up
when I land on his website to collect my
email all this growth hacking things
many other people do enough the reason
at times I don't do it because at times
I do at a times I'm very comfortable
throwing the right hook is because I do
believe in the jab the jab not the jam
and the jam I believe that branding
matters I believe that there's a time
and a place
I believe there's context in this
setting yes I do think that in a 2015
world people watch this show they see
that I'm not trying to sell them
anything I'm bringing value of sitting
here during my favorite time in the
world which is jet sparking a lot of
time because I want to put out content
and I'm just trying to give the best
business advice that I can and I do
believe that when somebody stumbles
across this yes there gonna be a call to
action and they could click and they
could buy but by me asking for something
like sign up for this and buy that in
this video or in this world of YouTube
I'm also leaving away this situation
where that person can then look at my
name find this interesting control copy
it go to Google search my name go down a
rabbit hole and let me build brand
because I asked like everybody else out
there for the quick sale in this context
and I took away the chance for us to
kind of you know it's kind of like
relationships because I went to sleep
with that person on the first night
maybe I took away the chance for us to
get married I my friend and playing the
long game the depth game not the with
game so there's a time in a place for a
call to action a CTA but that isn't
every single at-bat every single time
every single channel because then you
just become a sleazy salesman
thank you for watching episode 22 thanks
for sticking with me through
all these episodes thanks for being with
me in my favorite place on earth and now
your question of the day next week the
New York Jets played the Detroit Lions I
need your prediction because you've had
the benefit of this game playing out
tomorrow already puts us tonight or
tomorrow tomorrow morning you've had the
benefit of this game coming out so maybe
like 36:14 prediction didn't work but I
need your Lions lock of the week Jets
this Lions that Lions this Jets that
little fun I want to see their skills if
somebody wins the exact score something
amazing might happen you keep asking
questions and I'll keep answering them
sorry dear ugh oh crap wait subscribe do
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social